WE'LL SEE HOW DR. FAUCI
RESPONDS.
>> Bill: WANT TO BRING IN
ADMIRAL BRETT GIROIR, FORMER
HHS ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
HEALTH.
GOOD DAY TO YOU.
CDC SAYS NO TO THE MASK.
OTHER PEDIATRICIAN GROUPS SAY
2-YEAR-OLDS NEED TO WEAR THEM
IN THE CLASSROOM.
IS THAT NECESSARY?
>> SO I STILL FIRMLY AGREE WITH
THE CDC IF YOU ARE FULLY
VACCINATED.
WE KNOW VACCINES ARE HIGHLY
PROTECTED AND YOU'RE PROTECTED.
IF YOU'RE FULLY VACCINATED YOU
SHOULD FEEL SAFE AND NOT HAVE
TO WEAR A MASK.
THAT GUIDANCE SHOULD CONTINUE
AND IS CORRECT.
IN TERMS OF THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS ONE THING
THEY SAID IT IS IMPERATIVE FOR
ALL KIDS TO GET BACK TO SCHOOL
IN PERSON.
THAT STATEMENT WAS MORE ABOUT
SOCIAL CHANGE AND SOCIAL POLL
SI AND IT WAS VERY LIGHT ON THE
SCIENCE.
I COMPLETELY DISAGREE THAT
CHILDREN OVER 12 WHO ARE
VACCINATED SHOULD WEAR A MASK.
I THINK THERE IS A STRONG
ARGUMENT THAT CHILDREN UNDER 12
SHOULD NOT WEAR A MASK OR AT
LEAST THAT SHOULD BE PART OF A
DEBATE AND NOT JUST --
>> Sandra: I THINK THE
CONFUSION FOR A LOT OF PARENTS
WHEN THEY HAVE THE AMERICAN
PEDIATRICS MAKING THIS
STATEMENT SUGGESTING SUCH THAT
KIDS AS YOUNG AS 2 SHOULD BE
WEARING MASKS AND THEN SCHOOL
AGE KIDS, KINDERGARTEN EVEN
SHOULD BE WEARING MASKS.
WHY ONLY LOOK AT ONE ASPECT OF
THIS?
THE SPREAD OF THE POSSIBLE
VIRUS BUT WHY ISN'T THERE ANY
CONCERN ABOUT THE LOST LEARNING
AND LOST PRODUCT ACTIVITY AND
SOCIALIZATION WHEN THEY DON'T
SEE EACH OTHER'S FACES?
WHY ISN'T THAT OF EQUAL
CONCERNS?
THESE ARE OUR KIDS AND THIS IS
OUR FUTURE.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
WE KNOW AND THERE IS INCREASING
EVIDENCE THAT CHILDREN ARE AT
INCREDIBLY LOW RISKS OF DEATH.
AND IT IS EVEN ARGUABLE THAT
ANY NORMAL CHILDREN OR
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS HAVE DIED.
A NEW REPORT OUT OF THE UNITED
KINGDOM SHOWED ONLY 25 PEOPLE
UNDER AGE 18 DIED OF COVID IN
THE ENTIRE LAST YEAR AND HALF
OF THOSE WERE CHRONICALLY ILL
ON RESPIRATORS AND FEEDING
TUBES.
WE NEED TO DEBATE THAT.
THE W.H.O. THAT CHILDREN WILL
BE SAFE.
WHAT THEY CITE THERE SAYS
CHILDREN UNDER 5 SHOULD NOT
WEAR A MASK AT ALL.
IT WILL INHIBIT THEIR SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT AND YOU SHOULDN'T
DO IT.
BETWEEN 6 AND 11 ONLY UNDER
VERY SPECIFIC HIGH-RISK
CIRCUMSTANCES.
EVEN THE MATERIAL THAT THE
A.A.P. CITES IS CONTRARY TO
THEIR RECOMMENDATION.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE ARE
CONFUSED.
>> Bill: JEROME ADAMS FORMER
SURGEON GENERAL CAME OUT WITH
QUITE A STATEMENT THIS WEEK.
HE SAID LAST YEAR TONY FAUCI
AND I FAMOUSLY PREMATURELY AND
WRONGLY ADVISED AGAINST MASKS.
I FELT IT WAS THE BEST CALL AT
THE TIME BUT NOW REGRET IT.
INSTEAD OF VACCINATE OR MASK
IT, IT SUGGESTS CDC SHOULD BE
VACCINATE AND MASK WITH CASES
WITH POSITIVITY UNTIL WE SEE
NUMBERS GOING BACK DOWN.
CDC WAS WELL INTENDED BUT THE
MESSAGE WAS PREMATURE AND WRONG.
YOU HAVE THAT OUT THERE.
FAUCI ON MONDAY OF THIS WEEK.
ROLL THIS.
CALL FOR NUMBER THREE, GUYS.
WATCH.
>> CDC RECOMMENDATIONS MAY BE
AT VARIANCE WITH THAT.
IN EFFORT RESPECT THE CDC
ALWAYS LEAVES OPEN THE
FLEXIBILITY ON THE PART OF
LOCAL AGENCIES, LOCAL
ENTERPRISES, LOCAL CITIES AND
STATES TO MAKE A JUDGMENT CALL
BASED ON THE SITUATION ON THE
GROUND.
I THINK THAT'S REASONABLE THING
TO DO.
>> Bill: HE TALKED ABOUT
FLEXIBILITY.
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE GROUND.
THIS NEW DELTA VARIANT, WHAT IS
IMPORTANT ABOUT KNOWING
HOSPITALIZATION RATES AND DEATH
RATES ABOUT THE VARIANT WHEN
YOU'VE ALREADY GOTTEN THE
VACCINE, MANY OF US?
>> SO LET ME MAKE IT CLEAR A
FEW POINTS THAT EVERYONE NEEDS
TO UNDERSTAND.
IF YOU ARE FULLY VACCINATED,
YOU ARE NOT 100% PROTECTED BUT
YOU ARE WELL OVER 90 TO 95%
PROTECTED EVEN AGAINST DELTA.
IT IS A GOOD RECOMMENDATION IF
YOU ARE FULLY VACCINATED YOU
DON'T NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
IF YOU'RE UNVACCINATED THE
DELTA VARIANT IS VERY
CONTAGIOUS.
60, 100% MORE CONTAGIOUS THAN
THE OTHER VARIANTS.
IF YOU'RE UNVACCINATED YOU ARE
SUSCEPTIBLE AND NEED TO WEAR A
MASK.
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S IMPORTANT
UNLESS YOU ARE AT AN AGE GROUP
OVER 85 OR YOU HAVE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS THAT IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED TO WEAR A MASK AS
WELL.
IT IS CERTAINLY YOUR OPTION.
MY 88-YEAR-OLD MOTHER IF SHE IS
GONE IN PUBLIC AND FULLY
VACCINATED WE TALK ABOUT
WEARING MASKS TO GIVE HER EXTRA
PROTECTION.
ASIDE FROM THOSE GROUPS YOU
SHOULD BE GOOD.
>> Sandra: IF YOU COULD IN A
COUPLE OF WORDS BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO LEAVE IT THERE.
WHERE ARE WE IN THIS?
WE FELT LIKE WE WERE LIVING IN
A POST PANDEMIC WORLD AND NOW
THERE ARE SO MANY MORE FEARS.
WHERE ARE WE WITH THIS?
>> WE ARE AT A VERY DELICATE
AND POTENTIALLY DANGEROUS POINT
BECAUSE THE DELTA VARIANT WILL
SPREAD AMONG THOSE WHO ARE
UNVACCINATED.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
OUR HOSPITALS ARE IN A VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION.
WE HAVE TREATMENTS, WE HAVE PPE
AND LOTS OF HOSPITAL CAPACITY.
BUT I DO URGE PEOPLE PLEASE GET
VACCINATED.
IT WILL PROTECT YOU AGAINST ALL
THE VARIANTS AND WE CAN PUT
THIS THING IN OUR HISTORY.
WE'RE STILL IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE FIGHT AND PEOPLE NEED TO
TAKE IT SERIOUSLY.
>> Bill: IN THE MIDDLE.
THANK YO